if you want to hang out and talk about
anime theories recommendations and other
fun stuff feel free to join us on
discord and twitch both links are in the
description what is up everybody its
Anna Mack here for anime uproar and in
this video we will be talking about
something very important that I noticed
in episode 129 of Dragon Ball super now
of course most of our focus in this
episode was on the epic showdown between
Goku and Jared as Goku finally attains
mastered ultra instinct right at the
very end of the episode but there is
another extremely important thing that
happened during this episode that is
very easy to miss because so much of our
focus was on the big fight as Goku
breaks through another barrier in order
to master ultra instinct what happens
off the fighting stage in the stands is
also extremely telling the gods of
destruction are so surprised and
impressed by what's happening that we
see them actually stand up to get a
better look even the grand priest says
to Zeno that we are witnessing a super
development but one person is completely
calm and doesn't stand up instead this
person has a knowing smile on his face
and that person is of course we's Wiese
knows exactly what is happening and if
we listen carefully in episode 129 we
see reveals the truth about Goku's
mastered ultra instinct its true nature
power and potential and that is what we
will be talking about in this video if
you enjoy the Dragon Ball super videos
on this channel be sure to leave a like
to let me know if you are new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell and if you
want to send us your fan art too maybe
have it featured in one of our future
videos or you just want to chat be sure
to follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar also i'm looking for
skilled video editors to help me edit
some videos so I can get more videos out
there every week so if that's something
you'd be interested in contact me on
Twitter or Instagram I will make sure
that you are fairly compensated for your
time
now throughout episode 129 we sis
kind of narrating the battle between
Goku and cheerin and explaining what is
going on to the others including to
beerus this is fitting because way back
in the golden Frieza saga
we's is the one who first introduces us
to the concept of ultra instinct while
training Vegeta and Goku and of course
back then we were told that this is a
rare technique which enables the user to
respond to attacks automatically without
thinking we says that this third time
that Goku goes into his ultra instinct
omen form in the tournament is his last
chance because the physical toll of
surpassing one's limit gets greater as
one steps into the state of the gods
according to Wiese the next time that
this silver glow disappears from Goku's
eyes the battle will be decided we all
remember the previous two times go who
entered the ultra instinct omen state
and while he is still in this incomplete
form in the first part of episode 129
Goku has the same problem as he did
against kefla we spoink out that when he
attacks Goku is letting his thoughts
interfere so he is not attacking without
thinking and this means that his blows
are much weaker than they would be if he
had mastered ultra instinct at first
Goku tries to use the same strategy on
jiren as he did on kefla by hitting him
with the kamehameha but jiren paid close
attention to goku strategy against kefla
and so goku is unable to take journal in
the same way Kiran was ready for it as
jiren and Goku continue to fight wheezes
observing things carefully and then
suddenly he says it looks like there's
nothing to worry about
we says he feels it an accelerating rise
of energy not from confusion but from
pure impulse Goku is focusing his heart
and soul on the battle he is heating up
and things like the universe is being
erased
things like hesitation panic and even
fear itself turned to nothing in the
flames
so as Goku lets go of all the stress and
pressure around him and begins to move
purely on the basis of impulse he dives
into a state deeper than instinct the
heat around Goku continue
to rise and everyone is shocked by how
intense this heat is as Jian appears to
have the upper hand in battle and
krillen Tian and the others become
worried
beerus tells them to just shut up and
watch even Bell Maud is sure of Durin's
victory but then Goku's movements
suddenly switch from defense to offense
as he learns to attack without thinking
Goku is beginning to unlock mastered
ultra instinct just as wheeze predicted
after all his initial transformation was
named Ultra instinct omen in the dragon
ball z dokkan battle game and omen means
a sign of things to come so I always
knew that another form was coming
Goku begins to generate a huge amount of
energy and heat all around him and jaren
does the same by powering up but then
Goku's energy suddenly extinguishes
Durin's flame now the question is how
was Goku able to just negate Durance
powerful energy and I think the answer
to this is that Goku's energy or his
flame at this point is stronger than
jiren and this goes back to my flame
theory that I talked about in previous
videos where I predicted that Goku final
form would have silver or white hair
there I said that in the Super Saiyan
God formed the hair and or a look a lot
like red flames and then because a blue
flame burns brighter than a red flame
the Super Saiyan blue is a step above
the Super Saiyan God form it makes sense
my prediction for Goku having white hair
was based on the fact that the brightest
flame possible burns with a blue-white
color blue around the outer edges and
white at the core closest to the source
of the flame and if you look at Goku's
appearance as he is transforming into
the mastered version of ultra instinct
it's crazy how much he looks exactly
like this brightest flame possible just
like this flame Goku is blue around the
outer edges and white on the inside so I
think the reason Goku is able to
extinguish gerron's energy here is
simple Goku's energy Goku's flame is
hotter than Durance at this point it is
a white-hot flame the strongest type of
flame possible compared to Joon's red or
orange flame and when you fight fire
with fire
the strongest flame win
at this point beerus asks Wease if goku
has finally reached the completed
version of ultra instinct and wheeze
answers yes with a smile on his face and
beerus then says honestly what an
unbelievable guy and I think that we now
have all the facts here the mystery of
Goku's ultra instinct has been revealed
and we have Wiis to thank for that
unlike the angels who seem to be able to
use ultra instinct as they please
Goku needs to attain a separate
transformation his appearance needs to
change in order for him to be able to
use this technique and this is probably
because Goku was born immortal so he has
to reach a different level to use a
technique that is so rare and difficult
to master or at least that's my guess
at first Goku succeeds in using ultra
instinct for defense and his appearance
changes his eyes turned silver his aura
becomes different his voice echoes but
he still cannot attack without thinking
so his transformation is incomplete it's
just a sign of things to come
we swooz the one who pointed out this
problem during the battle with kefla and
then when goku finally learns to attack
without thinking in episode 129 and his
hair turned silver or white wheeze is
the one who confirms that this is indeed
mastered ultra instinct and there is
another important thing that we stels us
when he says that Goku is focusing his
heart and soul into this battle for
getting all outside stress and pressure
and that is why he is able to master
ultra instinct that is why there is
nothing to worry about
why is Goku so unique and why is he able
to master ultra instinct when so many
others including gods of destruction
could not why does beerus say that goku
is an unbelievable guy i talked about
this in detail in a video called the
real reason why go who keeps getting
stronger but to be brief back when
wheeze is first training Goku and Vegeta
he mentions that Vegeta is very
strategic in battle and he likes to
think rationally but this sometimes
leads him to overthinking things and
this is why it is harder for vegeta to
master ultra instinct but Goku's
personality is much different than
Vegeta's Goku is much more child
and carefree by nature which allows him
to push unwanted thoughts aside and just
focus on the battle focus on fighting
without thinking and without
overthinking no matter how desperate the
situation becomes even if logically all
hope seems lost because his opponent is
far stronger Goku always refuses to
accept defeat and he just keeps fighting
you miss 100% of the shots you don't
take
and people who have a very rational and
realistic personality will not take the
shot if they think that the odds are
almost impossible but Goku will take
that shot every single time he doesn't
know the meaning of the word impossible
and that is why he succeeds where others
failed that is why he is the one who
succeeded in mastering ultra instinct
when so many others fail the entire
story of ultra instinct this whole
concept of ultra instinct goes all the
way back to the golden Frieza saga and
it was always Wiis who introduced it to
us and who explained it to us we really
has been our guide throughout this whole
thing for over 100 episodes even though
he is sometimes just talking in the
background while we're focusing on a big
fight like in episode 129 if we go back
and listen to week's
talk about ultra instinct over the
course of the series we can see that it
is Wiese who reveals the truth about
Goku's unique ultra instinct
transformation a form that has impressed
even the gods of destruction and the
grand priest
not to mention Zen oh one last thing
that I wanted to mention is that I made
a video a while ago talking about
Durin's power and how jiren has a really
unprecedented ability to anticipate what
is happening around him and what his
opponent is going to do next we have
seen this many times during the
tournament of power including when jiren
anticipates perfectly where the kochak
auction blocks will land so he doesn't
even move out of the way when everyone
else is hurrying to get out of the way
and of course in episode 1 - 9 jiren
anticipates that Goku will use the
kamehameha in his ultra instinct omen
form so Jian is able to overcome the
attack but now that Goku has mastered
ultra instinct now that Goku is both
defending and attacking without thinking
there is no way for jiren to really an
anticipate what Goku is going to do Goku
is moving too fast he is not even taking
time to think and this is why I think
mastered ultra instinct will be the key
to ultimately defeating jiren and that
is it for this video if you enjoy the
Dragon Ball super content on this
channel and you want to see more be sure
to leave a like to let me know if you're
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
if you want to share your Dragon Ball
theories or fan art with us be sure to
follow us at anime outpour on twitter
and instagram in this video I'm happy to
feature this fan art of Goku's mastered
ultra instinct by Christopher crazy
aka Cuusoo Marie he is a really skilled
and talented manga artist as you can
tell so be sure to check him out I'm
gonna leave the link to his YouTube
channel and his Twitter and Instagram in
the description as always thank you all
so much for watching I really appreciate
it and until next time see you space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]